ah
y los edificios se derrumban las
personas corren aterrorizadas
una estruendosa explosión te deja
tendido
y de repente entre los escombros y el
polvo un malvado villano un villano con
fuerza sobrehumana que está acabando con
todo a su paso y no hay nadie que los
pueda salvar
pero tú sólo tú tienes el poder de
convertirse en superhéroe en que
superhéroe te convertirías
yo hubiese elegido a la viuda negra
porque me encanta ese personaje es
bonita atrevida y muy lista
además me identifico por ser mujer
aunque si lo pienso bien creo que hulk
hubiera sido una mejor opción con su
súper fuerza con sus altos gigantes y su
poder en indestructible hubiera acabado
en un santiamén con ese villano
además de que me encanta su color verde
desde niña siempre fui super fan de los
superhéroes les confieso que me gustaban
más que las princesas de los cuentos y
siempre pensaba y pensaba cómo hacerle
para poder tener sus superpoderes así
que descubrí que había tres formas uno
era siendo super entrenada 2 era ser de
otro planeta y 3 era con la ciencia y la
tecnología
no sé si ustedes se habrán dado cuenta
pero la mayoría de los científicos
perdón de los superhéroes fueron creados
por científicos por ejemplo bruce banner
era científico antes de convertirse en
hölck tony stark un brillante genio que
creó su traje de iron man
peter parker que por andar de curioso en
un laboratorio científico toma la que le
picó una araña genéticamente modificada
y ustedes ya saben qué pasó entonces
pensé no tengo quien me super entrene
pues tampoco soy de otro planeta aunque
a veces parece
entonces solamente me queda la ciencia y
la tecnología
para ser científica primero necesitaba
estudiar la verdad es que no es la parte
más divertida pero sí es una parte muy
interesante al final de cuentas me
olvidé de mi objetivo de convertirme en
superheroína porque me encontré algo que
capturó mi atención por completo la
biotecnología
y así les puedo decir el día de hoy
que mi superpoder es compartir lo que
aprendí
desde que somos niños somos buenísimos
para
para probar para experimentar para
preguntar todo queremos descubrir todo
esto lo hace un científico entonces
todos somos científicos desde que
nacemos a ver vamos parte por parte
desde que somos bebés nos encanta probar
probar todo lo que tenemos a nuestro
alrededor como mi sobrino de ocho meses
que decidió probar las pastillas de baño
asier las pastillas de baño término más
azul que un pitufo y como podrán
imaginarse fuera del hospital
afortunadamente no ingirió nada para
probar las pastillas de baño le permitió
aprender que no son tan deliciosas como
parecen
después al cumplir tres años de edad más
o menos empezamos a preguntar somos
expertos en cuestionar a nuestros padres
los bombardeamos con mil porque eso es
algo así como
la luna no se cae
porque en el espacio no hay gravedad
porque
porque el espacio es diferente que la
tierra
porque así es el espacio
pues porque no sé ustedes que hubieran
contestado a esas preguntas yo la verdad
ni siquiera tengo las respuestas
y es así como los niños intentan
descubrir por su propia cuenta porque no
cuentan con las respuestas que necesitan
mi nombre es belleza soy mamá de
carlitos de 9 años y de liam de 5 y he
descubierto que mis hijos son buenísimos
para hacer experimentos
como cuando los descubrí tratando de
averiguar cuánta espuma podrían crear en
la regadera
por supuesto que no les aplauden y les
dije ustedes sigan con su investigación
mis pequeños científicos la verdad es
que no tuvieron un final nada feliz
es que como les decía hace un momento
desde que nacemos somos científicos
cuando somos niños todo es motivo de
curiosidad todo queremos probar
preguntar experimentar y descubrir
lamentablemente los adultos estamos
programados para reprimir los instintos
más creativos de los niños
siempre creemos que tenemos la razón
nadie nos gana
desafortunadamente acabamos con la
creatividad de los niños
pero saben que es más desafortunado aún
en un estudio realizado por microsoft en
2018 se encontró que las niñas de
alrededor de 11 años de edad se
interesan por materias de ciencia
tecnología ingeniería y matemáticas pero
al acercarse a la edad de 15 años
pierden el interés por completo a que se
puede ver esto
tendrá algo que ver la inversión que
hacen en ciencia y tecnología méxico
invierte tan solo el 0.5 por ciento del
producto interno bruto mientras que esos
países desarrollados invierten hasta 8
veces más
es evidente que el desarrollo de estos
países se debe en gran medida a la
inversión que hacen en ciencia
tecnología y educación
y es evidente también
que la oportunidad que está dejando ir
méxico es la ciencia
la ciencia es un pilar fundamental de
las ciudades sin ella crecemos lento muy
lento y eso es lo que pasa actualmente
en méxico y en el mundo
porque no fomentamos el amor por la
ciencia porque no llevamos la ciencia a
cada rincón
y es ahí cuando de repente nos damos
cuenta que se nos ha ido la infancia en
un abrir y cerrar de ojos y con ella la
posibilidad de convertirnos en futuros
científicos
es muy triste esta situación
pero es muy triste y quiero comentarles
lo que sucede en nuestro país en méxico
existen 241 científicos por un millón de
habitantes
mientras que en los países desarrollados
existen entre tres mil y siete mil
treinta veces más que en mexico
y disculpen un poquito por el nervio
está cañón muy cañón y me queda ahí mis
hijos cuando experimentaron
[Risas]
[Música]
gracias
[Aplausos]
entonces después después de ver esta
desafortunada situación encuentro que
tengo una gran misión en la vida mi
misión es educar con la ciencia educar
con la ciencia para crear los futuros
científicos más humanos y conscientes
que han pisado este planeta primero
empecé con mis hijos que se convirtieron
en mis primeros experimentos después con
los amigos de mis hijos que aumentaron
mi población de estudio y hoy después de
tres años de haber creado mi
emprendimiento en el turn kits mx
he hecho mi más grande descubrimiento
esta imagen revela mi más preciado
descubrimiento descubrí que la mente de
un niño que ha sido orientada por la
ciencia es más poderosa que los
vengadores y la liga de la justicia
juntos se pueden imaginar
la ciencia no tiene límites la ciencia
no es sólo para adultos las ciencias
para todos es para los niños y es la
base de un cambio generacional muy
importante en nuestro país y en el mundo
a través del tiempo han existido
científicos que han revolucionado
nuestro mundo
levante la mano quien conoce a este
científico
era de esperarse ahora levante la mano
quien conoce a jeyko einstein
ni una mano arriba
bueno creo que una por allá pero creo
que fue alguien que ya escuchó a mi
charla anteriormente jeyko beinstein era
el tío de albert einstein él enseñaba
ciencia y álgebra y jake junto al cap
padre de albert einstein montaron un
laboratorio donde iban a realizar
experimentos científicos de aquella
época
así que albert eisntein creció
impregnado de ese espíritu inquieto y
amante de la ciencia
una de mis científicas favoritas
rosalind franklin al cumplir 15 años de
edad decidió que quería estudiar una
carrera universitaria
pero su padre no veía con buenos ojos
que una mujer estudiara una carrera
universitaria así que su madre y su tía
le ayudaron y en 1941 logró obtener su
grado universitario
rosalind franklin hizo uno de los
descubrimientos más importantes de la
vida descubrió el adn lamentablemente el
premio nobel se lo ganó alguien más y no
fue sino hasta muchos años después
cuando se le dio su reconocimiento
otra científica destacada es heidi lamar
una actriz de hollywood clásico que
desde pequeña destacó por su
inteligencia
heidi era enemiga declarada del régimen
nazi
hizo un descubrimiento grandioso
inventó los torpedos teledirigidos
basados en una partitura de piano pero
saben que es lo más importante de esto
que su invento dio origen a algo mucho
más importante mucho más grande algo que
ella ni siquiera tenía idea
su invento dio lugar a los teléfonos
móviles los dispositivos gps el
bluetooth y las conexiones wifi por
favor pónganse depp y denle un aplauso a
estos tres científicos pero con herse de
pie que revolucionaron nuestro mundo
[Aplausos]
y qué decir de los cracks de la ciencia
y los modos el creador de tesla steve
jobs el creador de apple steven hopkins
con su estudio del origen del universo
ustedes no se han dado cuenta pero
tienen una gran misión en la vida su
misión
es ser steve jobs es ser la madre de
rosalind franklin
ser la mentora de hairy lamar ser el tío
de albert einstein
todos ustedes pueden ser científicos
todos ustedes pueden ayudar a convertir
a los niños en los futuros científicos
y para que pueda cumplir con su gran
misión en la vida
quiero que conozcan este gran tipo saben
quién es
es un tipo bastante sorprendente él dijo
el universo es lo bastante sorprendente
como para inventar las historias a los
niños
el relato el descubrimiento de su hija
sobre el ratón pérez y el hada de los
dientes cuando se le cae el primer
diente a su hija le dice hemos escuchado
que si pones el diente bajo la almohada
y en el lado de los dientes entonces al
siguiente día su hija le dice a mí ni
balada de los dientes y él le contesta
como sabes que fue el hada de los
dientes
la niña se queda pensativa y muy
confundida
y entonces
se le ocurre hacer un experimento
al siguiente diente pone trampas de
aluminio en toda su habitación para
atrapar al ratón pérez y pone atrapas
sueños para el hada de los dientes pero
no atrapó ninguno
entonces con base a sus resultados le
dice a sus amigos en el colegio podrían
ser nuestros padres los que están
poniendo el dinero bajo la almohada
cuando se les caiga un diente no le
digan a sus padres y vemos qué sucede
el diente permanecía y magnífico hizo un
experimento para saber si existiera el
ratón pérez el hada de los dientes
el mejor regalo para los niños no estar
en no está en dar los mejores regalos ni
los más costosos el mejor regalo está en
su capacidad de asombro si los niños son
bien motivados se convertirán en jóvenes
seguros creativos y con un gran nivel
intelectual
quisiera comentarles también que mi
mejor regalo ha sido ser biotecnóloga y
mi superpoder es enseñar ciencia y
quisiera darles un regalo a ustedes
también un regalo que ustedes ya tienen
que ya poseen pero que han olvidado y
para ello necesito que cierren sus ojos
pero los cierren de verdad cierren sus
ojos
transporten se a su infancia
la etapa que más los haya hecho felices
recuérdense descubriendo algo aquello
que les pareció asombroso fascinante que
los llenó de emoción
tal vez puede ser la primera vez que
cayó una gota de lluvia en su cara
o quizás cuando se descubrieron cuando
descubrieron el sabor del chocolate
dulce
o cuando se bañaron por primera vez en
el mar
quizás cuando terminaron de armar el
juguete que más querían
en sus rostros veo reflejado veo
reflejada esa satisfacción de viajar en
el tiempo
y descubrirá algo de volver a fomentar
su curiosidad
y eso mis amigos es descubrir y ahí es
donde empieza la ciencia abran sus ojos
por favor
para terminar mi charla
quiero enviar un mensaje
pero quiero que este mensaje llegue a
todos lados con mucha fuerza y que
ustedes se conviertan en los portavoces
este va para ti cuando alguien te diga
que la ciencia solo para genios no lo
creas la ciencia se aprende tú puedes
ser un científico si tú lo deseas
para los padres y maestros cuando un
niño te pregunte por qué no respondas no
se puedes contestar es muy interesante
tu pregunta averigüemos la respuesta
para los científicos dejemos de hablar
en difícil
los niños están esperando los llevemos
la ciencia a cada rincón
para mí méxico tu mejor inversión está
en la ciencia y la tecnología
por favor no la abandones una vez más
para mis niños mis queridos niños
ustedes tienen el superpoder de sacudir
la naturaleza preguntas jamás dejen de
ser científicos como dijo carl sagan en
algún lugar algo está esperando ser
descubierto y quiero que nunca olviden
que las ciencias de todos y todos
nacemos siendo científicos gracias
[Aplausos]